tu sais pourquoi je suis là
je suis là pour ça
carton d'audience pour le lancement de
Koh-Lanta 5 millions de cartes de
téléspectateurs meilleurs gain
historique en replay 1,4 millions
de la télévision française en flux ça me
fait plaisir ça fait plaisir ça voilà
bah ça me fait plaisir ça me fait
plaisir Koh-Lanta je les adore à
Koh-Lanta donc vous avez pris un million
plus d'un million 4 en une semaine avec
le replay mais c'est une vraie question
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est pas moi qui vais défendre
le mardi
il y a un truc qui était intéressant
parce que moi je viens avec des chiffres
parce que comme j'ai une mémoire
[Applaudissements]
a fait ce mouvement parce que ça marche
il est chiffré c'est qu'en gros sur la
case du mardi on fait plus 34 % qu'avant
sur la case du mardi sur les individus
plus 61% sur les ménagères plus 81% sur
les 15
241% en nombre non mais ça veut dire que
c'est Alexia ces chiffres tu les as où
là
de consommer la télévision et tu le sais
alors toi c'est particulier parce que
vous êtes en direct ouais c'est ça c'est
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu
particulier sur les émissions en direct
la preuve c'est que Miss France
fonctionne pas du tout merci
beaucoup ça me fait très plaisir
[Rires]
donc ça c'est quand même très nouveau
donc c'est le replay et d'autre part TF1
il y a un intérêt direct c'est sûr qu'on
surperforme sur une case qui était en
difficulté il y a
dans le vendredi est très en difficulté
sur TF1 donc en fait moi j'aurais
préféré faire un vendredi fort à samedi
fort avec Koh-Lanta et The Voice le
vendredi c'est très très dur pour moi je
suis producteur
c'est parce que vous Alexia vous parlez
à TF1 c'est comment TF1 justifie le fait
qu'il faut la laisser vous n'avez pas
oui ça augmente la case mais tout ça
en plus les replay attention
[Musique]
les replay j'imagine que la pub des
replay rapporte beaucoup moins d'argent
que la pub télé mais oui mais oui bah
oui
non mais ça traitement c'est pas mon
métier je pense que c'est à TF1 j'ai
quand même l'habitude de les côtoyer ce
sont des gens
extrêmement intelligent
et donc je pense que tout simplement
s'ils font ça c'est qu'il y a une raison
moi ce que je constate et ça c'est en
tant que producteur c'est qu'évidemment
la case est surperforme par rapport à
c'est pour ça que je disais pourquoi je
t'aimais là il y a Alexia c'est c'est
une bonne élève et elle défend toujours
et sa chaîne et tout ça tu veux que je
te dise non mais c'est vrai moi qui me
font ça même si je l'ai découvert
voilà on va pas se raconter l'histoire
dit les mecs ils nous ont mis dans un
jour
on va revenir là-dessus on viendra
surtout j'aurais qu'on vienne déjà sur
l'émission d'hier en tout cas et je l'ai
dit la semaine dernière je trouve que le
casting est très fort
cette année donc voilà donc ça c'est
déjà un truc donc vous en sortez le
mardi après c'est toujours mieux que ce
que ça se faisait avant forcément on
prime comment j'ai rien je vous le dis
je le redis hein
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est Emine qui a été éliminé de
l'aventurier Emine
ah merde tu m'appelles voilà pourtant il
avait tout pour sauver sa peau mais rien
n'a marché mais Chine regardez
et cette semaine c'était à l'équipe
rouge d'éliminer quelqu'un de leur
équipe et ils ont une petite idée sur le
nom à mettre dans l'urne
sinon on va se mettre une balle dans le
pied si on fait pas sortir immunité
quand même la personne la plus faible et
oui malheureusement pour lui de son âge
bah forcément c'est plus difficile et il
est plus petit il faut voter une bon ça
a l'air compliqué pour Emy mais
heureusement il pourra compter sur ces
deux potes dont un qui a talisman et qui
pourra donc le sauver
la vérité je vais le mettre pour moi bon
il lui reste un pote c'est mieux que
rien
mais si je dois le faire peut-être que
je le vois on va pas se mentir ça sent
un peu la babouche là pour Emine il
faudrait le coller d'immunité je vois je
vois rien d'autre
bah non parce qu'il a juste trouvé un
double vote qui va lui servir à rien
[Musique]
Amy Emy Emy Émile émy
Emine les aventuriers de la tribu rouge
ont décidé de vous éliminer et leur
sentence et tirez vos caps
Emine
et de Koh-Lanta alors on va parler de
tout ça avec Alexia qui est merci d'être
là ma chérie alors la semaine dernière
on va revenir bien sûr sur le
commentaire de cette semaine et la
semaine dernière c'est vrai qu'on a eu
Pascal qui était là qui est un ancien
candidat de Koh-Lanta et c'est vrai que
bon apparemment ils partira pas en
vacances avec Denis Brogniart je crois
que c'est pas prévu pour cette année
c'est vrai que c'était des fois alors on
a vu
derrière Cédric bon tout le monde a
communiqué il y a eu des anciens
candidats qui ont dit voilà Denis
Brogniart qui est formidable de
limognard manger du manioc le monde
Denis Brogniart voilà comme c'est vrai
aimer la vie quoi et c'est vrai que ça a
été un changement de l'impression que ça
a été un peu panique à bord oui oui moi
justement je voulais vous entendre
là-dessus qu'est-ce que vous pensez
justement du cas de ni Brogniart est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est le maillot je
trouve que c'est pas le bon terme alors
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le
maillon faible il a quand même été il y
a quelques semaines dans une sorte de
tourbillon médiatique avec des il a été
il a été dans un tour et qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous alors moi je peux en
parler de temps plus que ça fait 7 ans
que je collabore avec lui que je suis
patronne d'une société avec lequel il
collabore que moi je n'ai jamais assisté
à des énervements oui il est soupeé
alors déjà il est soupelé unisexe il
peut être sous poulet avec un mec une
gonzesse ça n'a franchement voilà il est
extrêmement exigeant c'est vrai et que
dans des conditions de directe parce que
les deux événements se sont passés dans
des conditions directes sur TF1
face à une collaboratrice c'était pas un
lien de subordination voilà il est sous
pollué donc en effet il s'est énervé je
trouve ça déjà admirable qu'il se soit
quand même excusé tout de suite
non non mais tu sais très bien qu'il y
en a qui le font pas et sincèrement ça
s'est passé
deux fois dans une carrière de 30 ans
voilà je trouve que quand on parle de
harcèlement moi je suis allé voir la
diffusion du harcèlement le harcèlement
c'est une répétition de pression
physique et psychologique en
l'occurrence
de tennis à Mathieu Delon
je pense que Denis n'était pas conscient
en effet de de l'État peut-être de
fragilité dans lesquels étaient la jeune
femme du 14 juillet si j'ai bien compris
et Charlotte pourra qu'un gros caractère
je pense qu'elle était pas fragile mais
elle a été choquée donc quoi qu'il en
soit ça pour le coup c'est évidemment
c'est pas acceptable néanmoins on est ni
dans du harcèlement ni enfin ni dans un
lien de subordination il a pas demandé
leur tête à aucun moment il a été
question de ça Charlotte n'aimera elle
était là la semaine suivante à ses côtés
mais ça je sais qu'il y a pas de
conférence de rédaction sur cette
émission il y a une conférence de
rédaction sur auto-moto en effet
Automoto mais pas sur cette émission
dans quel monde
sur l'émission sur la Coupe du Monde
de Koh-Lanta en l'occurrence par rapport
à Denis Brogniart ou de choses comme ça
moi je vous dis en effet quelques fois
un peu souper et voilà mais
alors vous imaginez moi Patrick femme
face à un débordement sur une femme
c'est pas c'est pas acceptable donc
voilà sur oui alors lui il va être
chiant lui non non TF1 la convoqué quand
même pour savoir ce qui c'est exactement
passé est-ce que vous vous l'avez fait
et ce que vous songez vu toutes les
turbulences à le remplacer
à deux questions non pourquoi parce que
moi je pense que
je convoque quelqu'un quand il y a un
problème sur mes tournages
exactement
si maintenant je veux pas minimiser leur
ressenti on est bien d'accord en
revanche voilà on redescend d'un état on
a fait beaucoup de bruit là-dessus on
parle de 30 secondes 2 x 30 secondes
d'un mec est en direct qui monte un peu
dans les tours parce que il y a une
histoire d'exigence et de problèmes donc
c'est plutôt une grosse engueulade entre
collègues et je pense qu'on a tous ça et
moi ça m'est déjà arrivé de gueuler et
je pense que enfin je pense que ça nous
c'est tous arrivé
évidemment c'est tentant
et c'est un peu ça qui est difficile et
des jeux moi j'ai toujours beaucoup de
tendresse pour les gens qui sont un peu
en bas parce que
[Rires]
quelquefois d'accord et au fait que je
fais un peu gentille et il était assez
désappointé par le programme très
clairement et je me suis largement
exprimée là-dessus chez moi je pensais
avec une connerie même pour TF1 parce
que bien sûr on aurait compris ces deux
programmes différents
donc il est aussi dans des obligations
on lui dit voilà tu vas
Alexia je te dis la vérité c'est parce
que Alexia je le dis c'est un amour
voilà Alexia elle fait son taf elle s'en
fout elle avance je la connais par cœur
elle s'en fout de ses conneries mais
Alexia si elle avait vraiment été
chiante et si ça a été un mec plus
chiant il l'aurait dit il aurait dit
écoute Koh-Lanta c'est la marque phare
de TF1 c'est ta marque phare c'est la
marque avec laquelle tu as tu t'es fait
connaître c'est ta marque Cocody
bronnard dans la tête des gens c'est
Koh-Lanta tu vas aller faire le guignol
sur un autre jeu écoute-moi bien tu vas
rien faire du tout parce que sinon
Koh-Lanta on va essayer on va te
remplacer moi ça aurait été mes terres
après voilà chacun fait comme il veut
même pas eu besoin de faire ça le
programme c'est
19 mars écoutez c'est une grande fierté
c'est la réunion de deux grands ben
sportifs
voilà 5 médailles aux JO en biathlon
pour marque peu importe champion du
monde évidemment pour pires et c'est une
histoire de deux sportifs qui se
rencontrent sur le terrain de l'Ain en
l'occurrence elle va être le biathlon et
c'est un moment de complicité enfin
contre c'est on a réfléchi à comment
interviewer un sportif différemment que
des journalistes de sport et en fin de
compte c'est Robert Pirès qui va le
rencontrer et parce que c'est un sportif
qui lui-même a eu des échecs des
difficultés des blessures face à un
autre sportif il y a quelque chose
d'incroyablement intime et émouvant 19
mars sur Canal+ et sur C8 personne donc
je le dis je sais pas si j'ai le droit
d'en parler
au dessus de lui
il y a personne
elle va justement on peut en dire un mot
vraiment vraiment
le casting juste il y a un truc qui va
arriver qui est très fort je pense juste
alors le pitch si vous avez vu reste un
peu plus de Gad Elmaleh c'est ça c'est
la source d'inspiration de ce programme
c'est que on se dit dans une période où
tout va très vite ou on est sorti du
covid ou il y a des crises planétaires
et entre des guerres où on a du mal à
raccrocher avec les réseaux sociaux
peut-être que prendre le temps de
réfléchir comme la fait Gad Elmaleh en
faisant une retraite ça peut être un
moment enrichissant donc c'est pas sur
la retraite à 73
et il y aura donc des personnalités qui
vont être d'accord
tu vas pas m'envoyer en Inde deux
semaines non t'inquiète pas tu as pas
été sélectionné ce que je crois qu'il
faut pas parler pendant une semaine
toi ça serait compliqué c'est bien payé
oui
le Koh-Lanta d'hier parce que voilà on
en peut à parler on a parlé Denis
Brogniart tout ça hier on a découvert
Martin dans l'épisode hier soir Martin
quoi qu'il se passe il n'est jamais
content il y a jamais rien qui va Martin
c'est simple c'est un peu comme alors
ils m'ont mis ça en non je suis pas
d'accord c'est un petit comme si Raymond
faisait Koh-Lanta non vraiment il est
toujours de bonne humeur a-t-il à la
maison je lui donne un caprice des lieux
c'est le roi du monde
on sait pas que la fatigue maternelle
autant mais en fait je suis à bout de
mer je crois
aller chercher des feuilles parce que là
en vrai elle me regarde faire ça va pas
avancer je pense j'ai l'impression que
les gens ne regardent j'ai l'impression
que ça passe un peu au-dessus de la tête
de tout le monde que potentiellement on
peut se prendre un énorme orage j'ai un
bouton de fièvre qui est en train de
pousser ça me fatigue d'avoir de la
fièvre ça là ça un peu dur là Martin
nota
Martin et était excédé c'est pas tout à
fait orange pour être comme ça quoi
sinon dans le reste de l'émission il y a
eu d'autres rigolade la pire je commune
de Koh-Lanta c'est une chute magnifique
ou encore des questions chelou de Denis
Brogniart hier soir il y avait du lourd
sur Koh-Lanta
dans cet épisode de Koh-Lanta on est
tombé sur la meuf la plus poissarde de
deux tirages au sort de défaites la
Boule Noire sera exempté de jeux de
confort tendez le bras
retournez
[Applaudissements]
ouvrez
le bras
retournez
la loi des séries c'est dur Elodie il en
a d'autres des questions de Johnny comme
ça lui ah on me dit que oui question
collégiale
est-ce que l'estomac commence à crier
famine ça fait plus de 10 jours qu'ils
ont pas bouffé les gars de toute façon
il pouvait pas les blairer Denis et
c'est de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'une
défaite c'est une raclée et enfin on
termine avec le Belmondo de Koh-Lanta le
Rémy Julienne des îles désert
[Musique]
il y a un autre truc
un moment sur une épreuve de confort ils
ont gagné un kit de pêche le problème
c'est qu'il n'a pas accès
des catastrophes on pêche
qui s'est péchés qui peut apporter du
poisson oh mais c'est du poisson c'est
pas compliqué en plus il a un fond le
gars allez premier essai
voilà c'était un rocher et deuxième
essai
[Musique]
du dimanche bon allez avec un filet
normalement ça devrait mieux se passer
tu vas aller chercher seven pour qu'ils
puissent nous aiguiller comment jeter le
filet de jeter le filet quand tu pêches
c'est très important allez c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]